sur ce plateau mathieu ball reda nous a
rejoint secrétaire du syndicat cgt
cheminots de versailles dans les
yvelines bonjour merci avec vos
premières questions vous arborer un
t-shirt avec le mot riot écrit en
anglais ça veut dire émeutes c'est de la
provocation
non je suis look et 6 à 15 ans chacun
son look nom à côté
oui ça représente bien ce qui se passe
depuis depuis un mois et demi il ya un
soulèvement populaire il ya un
soulèvement de la classe ouvrière et à
soulèvement des consciences qui
s'exprime bien sûr dans la grève qui
s'exprime dans les manifestations et qui
s'expriment aussi qui dans les sondages
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est complètement isolé
autour de la secte la république en
marche les sondages encore c'est un bon
hier même après l'annnonce du premier
ministre les sondages montrent que les
français continuent à être
majoritairement ultra majoritairement
contre la réforme et a même être très
majoritairement en soutien à la grève
alors parier sur nadia quand même un
sondage publié hier dans le jdd pour
ifop pour le journal du dimanche donc 71
% des français sont favorables à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
notamment à la sncf et à la ratp qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ça oui mais après
femmes
si vous les mois à la limite je suis
pour occire je suis pour l'alignement de
tout le monde par le mot il comprit
tient peut-être sur celui de cheminots
si on se trouve si favorable ou pourquoi
pas sur celui des sénateurs mais je
crois que c'est pas le débat en vérité
c'est pas du tout le débat de cette
réforme c'est le lange image qu'a voulu
faire croire le gouvernement du départ
c'est de dire l'idée c'est de 2to
fusionner en un seul régime donc de
supprimer les régimes spéciaux mais ce
que sont rendus compte les français
progressivement au fur et à mesure c'est
que c'est pas la question la question
ces deux dom gradés tout le monde certes
faire baisser les pensions de tout le
monde
en calculant la retraite la pension sur
toute la carrière terres potentiellement
40 ou 45 ans plutôt que sur les 25
meilleures années ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui dans le régime général va
concerner tout le monde
faire travailler tout le monde plus
longtemps prendre le risque de
c'est les pensions déjà liquidé avec
vous savez le fameux plafond qui veulent
introduire à 14.2 pibe de l'ensemble des
retraites du montant des retraites
versées dans le pays fait peser le
risque sur les retraités qui ont leur
retraite déjà liquidé d'avoir leur
pension qui baissent comme ça a été le
cas d'ailleurs en 2008 en suède
donc je pense que les français sont ceux
rendus compte et c'est pour ça qu'ils
soutiennent majoritairement la réforme
dans l'opinion aussi mais en soutenant
la caisse de grève
donc il ya les syndicats comme le vote
la cgt comme force ouvrière comme sud
rail qui à bientôt pour la compris au
retrait total de cette réforme les
syndicats dits réformistes comme la cfdt
ou l'unsa qui semble se satisfaire des
annonces récentes d'edouard philippe
notamment sur le retrait de l'âge pivot
est ce que ça veut dire cette division
au niveau des syndicats et qui va y
avoir des conséquences pour la suite du
mouvement
il n'y a aucun élément nouveau les
syndicats peuvent alors d'abord vous
avez oublié dans densité dans
l'intersyndicale donc je le rappelle cgt
fo solidaires et pas seulement sud rail
mais aussi fsu et la cgc qui à mon avis
ne lie syndicales la cgt la
confédération générale des cadres qui
n'a jamais été à l'avant-garde de
de la révolution bolchévique mais les
autres organisations comme la cfdt la
cftc ou l'unsa
depuis le début soutiennent la réforme
elles ne sont pas dans la grève
en tout cas pour leur direction
nationale je parle pas de la cfdt
cheminots l'unsa ratp mais elles ne sont
pas dans la grave elles ne l'ont jamais
été donc elles ne sortent pas du
mouvement ce lara cela n'aura aucune
conséquence sur les grévistes
aujourd'hui la cfdt n'est pas un
syndicat gréviste
elles ne représentent pas les grévistes
et dans les assemblées générales je n'ai
entendu personne ne parlait de la
question du retrait de l'âge pivot
personne n'est 40 jours depuis qu on ne
40ème jour aujourd'hui personne n'est 40
gens en grève pour le retrait de l'ex
pivot
donc cela n'aura aucun effet en vérité
d'ailleurs au lendemain de l'annoncé au
39e jour de grève sur ma gare la gare de
versailles chantiers il y avait zéro
euro versé comme au 38e jour
donc ça va a eu aucun effet donc
quarantième jours de grève on vient de
le dire on vient de voir également avec
thomas bonnet à pantin et chez vous
également dans les yvelines
quarante jours ça commence à faire
beaucoup les les conditions de vie
commence à devenir compliqué en cours
pour les grévistes dans le même temps on
a entendu edouard philippe dire nous
allons aller au bout ce rapport de force
quelle issue est ce qu'il peut avoir est
ce que les grévistes
qu'est ce qu'ils font au final parce que
on entend certains grévistes jusqu'au
boutiste dire je vais
prendre un crédit je vais vendre ma
maison ils sont pas tous dans cette
situation ça va commencer à devenir
compliqué si vous c'est votre salaire
qui fait que vous pouvez vous logez vous
chauffez acheter à manger
donc si on vous retire votre salaire
parce que vous êtes en grève c'est le
concept est bien évidemment ça va
commencer à tirer ça va commencer à être
très très difficile il ya des cagnottes
elles ont été largement commentés dans
la presse mais elles ne suffiront pas
évidemment à remplacer des salaires
elles aideront les gens pour les besoins
de première nécessité et oui ça va être
compliqué je vois qu'il ya un
gouvernement qui est très brutale par
rapport à ça parce qu'il sait ce qui
fait sa son objectif
vu qu'il a pas réussi à retourner
l'opinion contre nous il n'a pas réussi
n'a pas réussi à diviser le front
syndical non plus l'intersyndicale est
la même qu'au 5 décembre
et bien maintenant son objectif c'est le
pourrissement c'est appauvrir les gens
c'est nous étouffer financièrement pour
nous forcer à céder à mettre genou à
terre genou à terre ce gouvernement très
brutale qui n'est pas qui n'est pas dans
la discussion là on a bien compris que
monsieur macron est très têtu et têtu
comme une mule mais nous aussi on est
déterminés jeu en ariège terre de qatar
terre de résistance ont dit que ou la
mule s'arrête l'ariégeois continue nous
on continue
vous venez de parler de d'étouffement
financier il ya des petits commerçants
qui sont dans cette situation à cause de
la grève certains qu'ils sont cons des
difficultés économiques proches de
fermer ya également des parents qui sont
obligés de garder leurs enfants qui ne
vont pas au travail du coup qu'ils
perdent
des journées de salaire qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ces personnes en
difficulté aux victimes collatérales de
la grève
alors je tiens à dire qu'il ya aussi des
parents de grévistes un qui en plus de
perdre leurs journées de salaires
doivent doivent garder leurs enfants en
les confiant nous et c'est bon moi je le
déplore et j'ai d'ailleurs entendu
l'appel des commerciaux y compris à noël
ça date pas d'aujourd'hui qui disait il
faut faire une trêve nous on est
asphyxié financièrement et surtout en
région parisienne et qui est je crois un
quart du pib de la france
assez catastrophique m'enfin je
l'entends complètement mais je pense
qu'il faut pas se tromper
d'interlocuteur c est monsieur macron
qu'il faut s'adresser c'est monsieur
macron qui annonce une réforme avec une
grande brutalité qui refuse de négocier
qui refusent de laroque la retirer qui
veut avancer en force à tout prix y
compris au prix de pour la france
perdent 1 point de pib
y compris au prix que mon entreprise et
perdu quasiment un milliard d'euros je
crois qu'on est à 800 millions d'euros
ki moon 100 millions l'acier dernier
doit vraiment une direction mais ce
farandou parler de 700 enfin bon c'est
pas grave on n'est pas à 100 millions
près à priori ça n'a pas l'air de
déranger grand monde en tout cas pas le
gouvernement je pense que le
gouvernement au lieu d'avancer de
violenter ce pays et d'avancer avec
beaucoup de brutalité contre l'avis de
75% des français contre le fait qu' il à
sa population dans la rue et que la
grève est effectivement très très
puissante
il devrait faire preuve de
responsabilité réconcilier les français
justement dire ben je retire cette
réforme par un point anecdotique de
cette réforme
je retire cette réforme et j'ouvre
effectivement un calendrier de
négociations avec les organisations
syndicales représentatives sur la base
de l'europe de leurs revendications je
pense qu'il ne subirait pas faire ça au
contraire il se grandirait cénotaphe un
merci à monsieur bolloré d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire du syndicat cgt des
cheminots de versailles département des
yvelines